baltimore una ciudad puente entre el
norte y el sur de eeuu y espejo de los
problemas sociales del país roby louis
es delegada estatal del distrito 46 de
la ciudad un barrio que antes estaba
segregado por las leyes raciales hoy en
día los afroamericanos y los
estadounidenses blancos conviven allí
pero sigue habiendo discriminación
baltimore estuvo atrapada entre el norte
y el sur durante la guerra civil
esta historia sigue afectando a todos
los habitantes actualmente aquí estamos
en la frontera entre un barrio blanco y
uno negro en el pasado las líneas rojas
se utilizaban para delimitar estos
barrios y así sigue siendo había leyes
que estipulaban que uno no podía
venderle su casa a un judío oa un negro
y se les llamaba pactos te lo digo
bienvenidos a eeuu
baltimore al igual que cliff land o
ferguson es a menudo estigmatizada es
tristemente célebre porque su tasa de
delincuencia es superior a la media
nacional
donald trump contribuyó en gran medida a
mantener esta idea atacando públicamente
la ciudad varias veces llegando incluso
a decir que vivir allí era como vivir en
el infierno para robin louis la nueva
administración debe reparar a toda costa
la división social y racial que trump
fomentó durante los últimos cuatro años
quiero escuchar que yo bai bendiga los
veo y sé por lo que pasaron y quiero
escuchar sus ideas para encontrar
soluciones
hertz un west antiguo cuando tienes un
cargo público tu deber es hacer que los
fundamentos funcionen jordi ricart
basics si eres capaz de enviar una
computadora sobre ruedas a marte pero tu
pueblo no tiene un lugar seguro donde
vivir
los niños se envenenan con plomo al
beber agua del grifo las prisiones están
llenas y las bibliotecas vacías entonces
realmente hay que hacer algo en ti y
united states en las prisiones de
baltimore como en el resto de estados
unidos la mayoría de los presos son
afroamericanos maryland tiene una de las
tasas de encarcelamiento más altas del
país una población que a menudo no tiene
los medios para defenderse en los
tribunales
podrías levantar esos pedazos de madera
cuando termines de cortar eso gracias
con el fin de luchar contra esta crisis
judicial la asociación project serve
acoge a los presos inmediatamente
después de su salida de prisión y les
ayuda a reintegrarse a la sociedad cada
día durante cuatro meses limpian unas 50
propiedades en la ciudad
driver arts tiene 31 años salió de la
cárcel por segunda vez después de cuatro
años y medio
pero esta vez tiene toda la intención de
no volver
la gente como yo o como nosotros
caballeros que están aquí y acaban de
salir de la cárcel no estamos
acostumbrados a que nos den una
oportunidad este programa nos da una
gran oportunidad de mostrar que podemos
hacer algo con nuestras vidas
mucha gente necesitaría este tipo de
ayuda pero no la reciben
la misma síndico vinton fue parte de
este programa antes de convertirse en
tutora con la llegada de joe biden le
gustaría que el gobierno federal apoyará
y expandir estas iniciativas por todo el
país
si pudiera hablar con el presidente
piden le pediría que se asegurará de que
todos tengamos una oportunidad justa un
nuevo comienzo y le diría que la prisión
no siempre es la respuesta especialmente
para nuestros jóvenes lo que necesitan
es orientación así que si pudiéramos
expandir estos programas y obtener más
fondos esa sería una solución
durante la campaña presidencial joe
biden prometió hacer una profunda
reforma del sistema judicial
estadounidense una promesa que la
comunidad afroamericana espera sea
cumplida recuerdan que biden aprobó la
ley del 94 responsable de la explosión
del encarcelamiento en el país
[Música]
cristian hayley es consultor político
estudio en la universidad howard una de
las 107 universidades históricamente
negras de eeuu según él el país se
encuentra en un momento decisivo de su
historia lo que vemos hoy en día a
escala nacional es una forma de
reconciliación entre algunos
estadounidenses tanto políticamente como
en las relaciones raciales
por supuesto hay un gran contraste entre
la administración de obama multiétnica y
la supremacía blanca de los años de
trump baltimore es como un laboratorio
un microcosmos de todas estas cuestiones
históricas étnicas y raciales eeuu la
sociedad estadounidense y la clase
política deben ahora mirarse en el
espejo y decidir quiénes quieren ser
realmente
quienes quieren ser y qué modelo social
quieren adoptar especialmente en materia
de salud con más de 35 mil casos
confirmados baltimore fue duramente
golpeada por el cob y 19
ni la fe es neurocirujano hace parte de
la clase media blanca de baltimore nos
recibe en su casa porque el hospital
donde trabaja no acepta visitas para él
la pandemia debe ser una prioridad de la
nueva administración
y el tratamiento médico de los pacientes
con kobe limita el número de camas
libres en el hospital al igual que en
otros países nos vemos obligados a
limitar ciertas cirugías lo que espero
de esta administración es antes que nada
que joe biden use una mascarilla este
simple gesto será un ejemplo para el
resto del país te mostrará lo que es una
respuesta firme una respuesta federal
como los 80 millones de estadounidenses
que votaron por joe biden rubin louis
cree en la posibilidad de tener un país
unido y baltimore también cree en esto
este solía ser mi distrito antes el
barrio está cambiando y es algo bueno
concretamente la nueva administración
tiene dos años para iniciar un cambio
social antes de las próximas elecciones
de mitad de período en noviembre de 2022